[TITLE MUSIC PLAYING]
NATALIE NUÑEZ: I
am Natalie Nuñez.
On behalf of Talks at
Google, HOLA, Bay Area
Chapter, and the Hispanic
Heritage Month, we welcome you.
And thank you so much for
being here, as well everyone
in the audience.
We're very honored to
have a phenomenal--
ISABEL ALLENDE: Thank you.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: --brilliant.
ISABEL ALLENDE: I am honored.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Aw, thank you.
And give Isabel a
round of applause.
It's very exciting
to have you today.
[APPLAUSE]
So for other people
in the audience,
and those who are live-streaming
in, a little bit about you,
Isabel.
You've written 23
books, and it's
been translated
into 35 languages.
Your words have
literally reached
across all ends of
the earth, and have
been adapted into movies,
and ballets, and plays.
And we're just very excited
to see what more you
have in store for us.
You've received the
highest civilian honor,
the Medal of Freedom, by
former President Barack Obama.
You actually carried the
torch in the Olympics--
in the Winter Olympics.
ISABEL ALLENDE:
That was a fluke.
[CHUCKLING]
I have never done any
sports in my life--
nothing.
I can't even walk.
And I had to carry the
flag in the Olympics.
Go figure.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Well, we were
happy to have you represent--
ISABEL ALLENDE: Thank you.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: --Latin America,
and women all over the world
in that.
You've received a lot of
awards and honorary doctorates
from universities, a very,
very successful woman.
ISABEL ALLENDE: For someone who
hardly finished high school,
all those honorary
degrees seem very ironic.
[NATALIE CHUCKLING]
Yeah.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: So it's to say
that we shouldn't have gone
to high school.
[CHUCKLING]
But no, we're absolutely
thrilled about all the works
that you've given
us to the world.
And you continue to give back.
You give yourself back with
the Isabel Allende Foundation,
that empowers women and
girls all throughout Chile
and California.
And we're amazed by the
words that you have for us,
and the actions that
you continually give.
ISABEL ALLENDE: Thank you.
Thank you.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: So I think
I would like to start from
the beginning, from how you
became the person you became.
Someone born-- a
girl born in Peru,
a Chilean girl born in
Peru, and came here,
and had stories of love, and
mystery, and coincidences.
Can you tell us a
little bit about that?
ISABEL ALLENDE: Well,
I wasn't planning
to be a writer, really.
I was born in the middle
of the second World War,
in a very conservative Catholic
patriarchal environment.
And I was supposed to be
somebody's wife and somebody's
mother.
It didn't work out for me.
I didn't have the raw
material for that job.
No, not at all.
So I was very rebellious
even when I was very young.
I sort of realized that being a
woman was not to my advantage.
Because I saw my mom--
I saw that my mama, in the
household where we lived--
we lived with my
grandfather and my uncles.
The males had all the
privileges, and my mother,
who was the only woman, didn't.
And she didn't have
any money, and she
didn't have any independence.
I didn't want to be like her.
So I think I became a
feminist around age 5,
before the word was
invented in Chile.
And then I became a
journalist in Chile--
worked as a journalist.
I did everything except radio.
I did television, newspapers,
magazines, you name it.
And then we had a military
coup in Chile in 1973.
And very soon, I had to
get out of my country.
And I went as a
political refugee
to Venezuela, where I could
not find a job as a journalist.
So I worked in all kinds of
odd jobs to make a living
and support my kids--
two kids, and at least one dog.
And then by 1981, I was
working administering a school
in Caracas.
That was not the job for me.
I can't even add or subtract.
And I had to deal with
checkbooks, and with money.
And it was just
a total disaster.
But they kept me
for like four years.
And during that
time, in 1981, I got
a phone call that my
grandfather, whom I adored,
was dying.
And I could not return to my
country to bid him farewell.
So I started a letter, which
was like a spiritual letter.
I would write to him often.
But this was a different
letter, because I wasn't sure
if he was going to
be able to read it.
And I wanted to tell him that
all the stories that he had
told me-- and he was a
wonderful storyteller--
I remembered them.
I had them all with me.
It was my-- they represented
my background, my roots,
my family, everything
that I had left behind.
And I think that, in a way,
as a political refugee,
I felt an overwhelming
nostalgia.
You sort of idealized that
country that you left.
There's a reason why
you left, because you
couldn't live there.
But still, one idealizes it.
And the idea is to try
to go back all the time.
So the letter for my grandfather
was about the stories
that he told me.
And the first story was
the story of my Aunt Rosa.
My Great Aunt Rosa was my
grandfather's first fiancee,
and she died in
mysterious circumstances
before they could get married.
So eight years later, he
married the youngest daughter
in the same family,
with the idea
that if he had
been accepted once,
he would be accepted
the second time, too.
So that's why he married
my grandmother, who
nobody wanted to marry,
because she was so weird.
She was adorable,
but totally weird.
She lived in another world.
She was always experimenting
with the paranormal.
So my first few years were with
this wonderful grandmother.
And there was a table--
a very heavy Spanish
table where my grandmother
would have the seances.
And she would call the
spirits with her table.
And they say that the
table would jump twice
for yes, one for no.
I have the table in my house.
I've tried everything.
[CHUCKLING]
You need two men
to move the table.
So I don't know how she did it.
But there must have
been some trick there.
So with that background,
with that family,
I think that it was
only natural that I
would have to write about it,
about that grandmother, who
is Clara del Valle in "The
House of the Spirits,"
my first novel.
So the idea was to tell
my grandfather that I
remembered what he had told me.
And the first
story in the letter
was the story of
my Great Aunt Rosa.
And then I kept on writing--
he died-- and I couldn't stop.
And it was the
memories of the family,
things that I invented,
that I made up,
and the history of my
country for 70 years.
So it was a micro-world of
the family that reflected
the macro-world of the country.
And so that's "The
House of the Spirits."
Of course, I didn't
plan it that way.
It just happened.
Later-- this book was
written 35 years ago.
And now that the book has
been studied and whatever,
people tell me all this.
[LAUGHTER]
Because I didn't plan it.
So if you ask me what
the book is about,
I'm telling you what
the reviewers have said,
not what I had in mind.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: So knowing now
the reach that that book has
had, would you have done
anything differently?
Would you have--
ISABEL ALLENDE:
Well, you know, I
was-- we were talking in the
car that I never read my books.
Because there's so much
that you can correct.
You can correct forever.
Also, what was OK at the time
is totally politically incorrect
today.
There are certain terms
and certain things
that you can't say
today, not even in Chile.
In Chile, we have
very little idea
of what politically correct is.
In Venezuela, even less.
But still, there
are things that you
don't say anymore
in this century
that we are living today.
Too bad, because they were
very colorful, actually.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Do you think
that the Spanish language has
morphed the way that you
think, in terms of femininity
and masculinity?
And as that's being translated
to these other books,
is there anything that's
lost in translation?
ISABEL ALLENDE:
Well, as we all know,
in the Spanish language
you cannot change--
every adjective has
gender because it
applies to a noun
that has gender, which
doesn't happen in English.
So for example, I
have a granddaughter
who is into the LGBT, et
cetera, and she has asked
me to change the pronouns.
In English, being the
second language for me,
it's pretty hard.
But to translate
that into Spanish
is almost impossible,
because every adjective
would have gender.
And so I can't handle
it in Spanish that well.
In that sense, it's a
very different language.
The other thing
with Spanish, also,
is that it is a less flexible
language than English.
In English, everything
can be turned into a verb.
You can add other words.
You can put words together
in wonderful ways.
Spanish is very strict.
So you have to stick to
grammar and spelling of course.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: And you've been
called "the most widely-read
Spanish language author."
And you have García
Márquez, and Jose,
and so many other
amazing authors.
Now that you see your
name among those,
does it change the
way you approach
new books and new stories?
ISABEL ALLENDE: No
it doesn't, because I
try to write from the womb,
not from the brain so much.
And I try to write
the best I can.
Whatever the critics say,
or how many books are sold,
or if they are compared to
somebody else's writing,
I can't worry about that.
And I don't even read the
reviews, because I get either--
I would say I get influenced.
I don't get upset,
because I understand
that if you do
anything in public,
people will criticize you.
Some people will like you,
and some people will not.
And I have to be ready for that.
So I don't get all upset
because something is bad,
and I don't celebrate too
much when something is good,
because everything passes.
It doesn't matter.
In the long run,
nothing matters.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: And out
of all these authors,
like José Donoso
and García Márquez,
was there any on
author that influenced,
and that you looked up to?
ISABEL ALLENDE: I
was in my late teens,
early 20s when I started reading
the big names of the boom
of Latin American literature--
at least 25, all male,
many of them with
mustache, males--
who wrote these fantastic books.
There were different books in
different countries of Latin
America, but all of them
formed a sort of harmonic choir
that, in a way, told the world
what Latin America was about,
and told us who we
were as a whole.
So I grew up reading them.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Yes.
And did you ever
know-- you know them
being male authors, was
there anything about you
that you wanted to share
differently that would impact
Latina literature?
ISABEL ALLENDE:
I didn't plan it.
I didn't think that way.
I just wrote what I knew.
And I had been working
for women, and with women,
and being a woman all my life.
So it was only natural that
my protagonists would tend
to be more female than male.
So when my book, "The House
of the Spirits" was published,
they said that I was the only
female voice in the boom.
And then they rapidly said, no,
she doesn't belong to the boom.
She's post-boom.
They didn't want a female
in the boom, of course.
So I'm post-boom,
whatever post-boom means.
And I never compared my
writing to what they wrote.
Other people did, but I don't.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Your writing was
definitely influential to many
other authors after this post--
ISABEL ALLENDE: What they say
is that, because my book was
so successful, even from the
start, publishers all over--
not only in Spain,
but all over--
realized that there is a
feminine readership that
wants to read female voices.
So there was a market
for female authors
that before they had
not maybe noticed.
And so in a way, that book
opened the door for other women
to be published.
And I feel very proud of that.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: It's wonderful.
And within these books,
you have powerful women.
Are these women portrayed from
real, live people in your life?
ISABEL ALLENDE: Do you
know any weak women?
[NATALIE CHUCKLING]
NATALIE NUÑEZ: I do not.
ISABEL ALLENDE:
Yeah, you do not.
OK, good.
[APPLAUSE]
No, I just pick up people
in the street, and people--
women that I know through the
foundation, extraordinary women
who are survivors of sometimes
the most horrible trauma.
And they not only survive,
they become leaders
in their communities.
So that kind of person, woman
or man, is always fascinating.
And I'm always attracted
to those people
who stand outside the big
umbrella of the establishment--
immigrants, refugees,
people who have other gender
choices, people who come
from different races,
from different ages.
I've been writing a lot
about very old people.
And some readers
say, why do you write
about these people
who don't even read
because they can't even read?
No, I am interested
always in what
is outside, not the mainstream.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: So including
these diverse characters--
ISABEL ALLENDE: Of course.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: --there
is a part of magic to it.
Magic is not normal.
You don't see that every day.
And--
ISABEL ALLENDE: Well, let's--
what's magic to you?
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Magic to me?
Or I guess the way I was I
was phrasing it is, you know,
the fire, and the poof, and
the, you know, out there.
But the magic that you see, and
that I read in your books is
natural, is in the real world.
ISABEL ALLENDE:
What I understand
is that we know nothing.
Maybe you here in
Google, you know more.
But normal people
know very little,
and normal people have
very little control
over their lives.
And everything that stands
outside that control,
that explanation of
life, is mysterious.
And in some cultures, like
America and many places
in Europe, what
you cannot explain,
what you cannot control,
and what you cannot sell,
you ignore.
It's not in the
realm of reality.
However, in most of the world--
and I would say all of Latin
America, all of Africa,
all of Asia--
we understand that there
are dimensions of reality
that we don't control, and
we don't understand it,
but we accept them.
For example, in
everybody's lives,
there are coincidences, those
moments in which you think,
I have been here before.
And you-- I know this place.
And you know that you
have never been there,
but somehow it's familiar.
Or a person that
you meet, and you
have the idea that you've
met that person before,
or I am thinking of someone,
and the phone rings,
and it's that person--
or dreams.
That kind of thing that
happens in everybody's life,
you all ignore it,
because you don't need it.
But in my life, in my country,
my culture, you use it.
You use it in everyday life.
It becomes part of--
it's integrated to life.
For example, my mom
died two weeks ago.
And she was wonderful, and we
had a very close relationship.
And she would write to
me every single day,
and I wrote to her every
day for 40 years or more.
So I have 40 years
of letters in boxes.
And every box has between
600 and 800 letters.
So multiplied by 40--
I can't multiply, but
you can Google it--
it's a lot.
And now that she's
gone, I thought, well,
why can't I write to her?
Maybe she cannot write to me any
more, but I can write to her.
Why not?
And so then I've
started writing to her,
and establishing
a connection that
is perfectly natural to me.
And I know that if I
write about it in a novel,
it would be either
crazy, or magic realism.
It's just life.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: So do you like
when people say that your work
is part of magic realism?
ISABEL ALLENDE: I think that
my work is very realistic.
It just accepts
what is mysterious,
but it's very realistic.
You know, García Márquez,
the master of magic realism,
explains it very wonderfully.
He says that in his book, "One
Hundred Years of Solitude,"
he has Remedios,
[INAUDIBLE] who rises
to heaven in body and soul.
The original story is
that in the village where
he lived, in the town where
he lived, a girl got pregnant,
and the family made her
disappear, sent her away.
And the explanation
the family gave was she
rose to heaven in soul and
body, like the Virgin Mary.
And nobody asked more
questions, because everybody
understood that no
questions were accepted.
But when he wrote that in
the book, it didn't work.
And he said he wrote it several
times, and it never worked--
until he had her hanging
the sheets to dry,
and the wind came and
lifted her with the sheets.
And then there is
sort of explanation.
It's a parachute
that elevated her.
With the sheets,
it's magic realism.
Without the sheets, it's
fantasy, like Harry Potter.
Isn't it interesting?
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Yes,
it is interesting.
And it's interesting to
hear that magic realism
within the Latino literature
is almost easier to understand
because we have spirits,
and we believe in--
ISABEL ALLENDE: But we
have spirits here, too.
I mean, all my
friends see psychics.
They hang crystals here.
They see the horoscope.
Everybody has a sign.
I mean, a zodiac
sign or whatever.
So what's the difference?
It has a different name.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Yeah,
it's interesting.
And do you speak
to them about that?
Do you connect those spirits
into the Latino community?
Meaning, for those that go
to psychics, and they speak--
ISABEL ALLENDE: Well,
we go to psychics, too.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Oh, that's true.
[CHUCKLING]
Is there a way that
you use this to impact
Latino literature-- or
not Latino literature,
but literature globally?
Like this idea of, everybody
believes in the same things.
Let me show you.
ISABEL ALLENDE: There are
wonderful literary devices.
When you can't solve something,
you introduce a psychic.
And it's wonderful.
The only time that
didn't work for me,
I was writing a crime novel.
And in a crime novel,
everything needs to fit.
So I couldn't introduce the
astronomer or the psychic,
unfortunately--
astrologer.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: So I'm curious,
because you've had a lot
of impact in not just Latino
literature-- global literature,
in representing the Latino
culture and Chilean culture
and history.
How do you see that
this is impacting others
in seeing Chilean history
in the books, and those--
ISABEL ALLENDE: I don't
know how it impacts others,
but I hope it does.
Because I try to--
I have written several
historical novels.
And well, when
you write fiction,
you have more freedom of
course, and that's wonderful.
But I try to present
an historical event
from the perspective--
from another eye, not the
perspective of the winners.
For example, I
have a novel called
"Island Beneath the Sea,"
and it is about the slave
revolt in Haiti.
And of course all
the history books
were written by white men--
French, or American, whatever.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: The winners.
ISABEL ALLENDE: The
winners, always.
We never have the perspective
of the poor people, the slaves,
the people of
color, the children,
the people who really
experienced the event.
So that's where I try to stand
as a writer and as an observer.
When I research for a historical
novel, I go to, if possible,
private documents.
Because if I read
the history books,
that's the official history.
And I want the other
history, what people
were saying in their letters.
I have a novel
about the Gold Rush.
We all know the Gold
Rush, because we've
read about it here,
written by the '49ers,
or the people who
followed the '49ers.
But long before the '49ers
arrived, people of color
were here.
Native Americans,
Mexicans, Peruvians,
Chileans, we were all
in the mines before.
And those voices have
been obliterated.
They don't exist.
And the women who came,
also, they don't exist.
So for that book, I went
to the library in Chile
to research letters the Chilean
miners wrote to their families
in Chile in 1850.
So I got a perspective
from another angle
that we never here
in the United States.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Yeah, that's
interesting to hear--
letters, the stories--
ISABEL ALLENDE: The stories.
A person-- in a letter,
for example, someone
can explain that a
bottle of champagne
was cheaper than
a glass of milk.
You never see that
in a history book.
And the reason is that there
was no one to milk the cows.
They were all looking for gold.
And champagne came
in ships from France.
So that was available.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Interesting.
So here at Google, similar
to you being a storyteller
and expanding the stories' reach
to people around the globe,
we write code, and
we make products,
and try to make these products
accessible to the world.
How do you see Google
being-- or yourself,
reaching out to these
greater audiences
with stories that have these
little details that aren't
communicated in other ways?
ISABEL ALLENDE: I love the
process of building a universe,
of details.
It is in the details that you
get the sitting, the theater
where the characters will move.
And the more details I can
find to make believable, then
the better that the reader will
believe the unbelievable, which
is the fiction.
So I create fictional characters
that move in a real world,
and that makes it more
believable for the reader.
Now, how that reaches other
cultures, I don't know.
But I love when I read a
book, for example, written
by an Indian author,
and I can see
how life is in India,
for that group of people,
and learn about them.
I find it fascinating.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: And do these
stories impact your stories?
Stories from all over
the world, I mean--
you don't--
ISABEL ALLENDE: Yeah.
My latest book--
what's the name?
[CHUCKLING]
What is the name
of the last one?
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Your latest book?
ISABEL ALLENDE: Yeah, I forgot.
Laurie.
"In The Midst of Winter."
Sorry, because--
NATALIE NUÑEZ: This
is a memoir, right?
ISABEL ALLENDE: No, it's not.
My latest book is fiction.
And I forgot the name
because I write in Spanish.
And I remember
everything in Spanish.
I can't remember
anything in English.
And in that book,
I have a character
that is a Guatemalan
undocumented migrant.
She's a refugee.
And she's running away from
the gangs in her country.
They have exterminated
her family.
I didn't have to
invent that character.
I had to reconstruct her world.
But that character,
we have cases
like that in my foundation.
We work with refugees.
And a story like that, I don't
have to create the story.
I just have to recreate
the village, the house,
the grandmother, the food,
the market, the voyage,
traveling all the way from
Guatemala, across Mexico,
to come to the United
States, the border,
living in clandestinity in the
United States, undocumented.
That's the world I need to
construct very carefully,
and sticking to the truth.
Because if I can be very
believable in that aspect,
then the character of Evelyn
Ortega will emerge as real.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: And in sharing
the stories of other people--
and you have memoirs of
your own life, "Paula,"
and a recent one.
Is there a difference
in the way you
go about writing other
stories versus your own story?
ISABEL ALLENDE: Yeah.
When I write a memoir, I'm
not writing about me alone.
I'm writing about me and the
people who are around me,
my family and friends.
And I ask myself, is
this my story to tell?
Am I betraying someone?
If I have to choose
between betraying my mother
or telling the story,
I tell the story.
Yeah, I can't resist.
But I understand that there
is a limit to how much.
So my way of handling it
when I write a memoir,
first, the problem is,
I write in Spanish,
but once it's translated,
or I have a sort of idea,
I show it to the people who
are named by name in the book.
And if they don't
approve, I take them out.
I don't change it,
but I take them out.
It has happened only once.
And I-- with the latest memoir
that I wrote a long time ago,
I promised my son that I
would never write another one.
And I haven't.
So much has happened since then.
I have so much.
And I can't, because I
promised Nico I wouldn't.
[CHUCKLING]
NATALIE NUÑEZ: So you
have your family here--
your son.
Having your family
near, and having
your mother be a
huge inspiration,
does that come across very
well in the love that--
Latinos are usually a very
communalistic community.
ISABEL ALLENDE: Yeah, but I
don't have the extended family.
I've tried to put together
an extended family.
And it worked for a while when
my grandchildren were little.
We sort of adopted friends
with their children
that were a part of this
almost compound where we lived.
And kids would come to the pool.
It would be an open house--
always open house.
And I had the feeling that I
belonged in that little tribe
where we all belong
in Latin America.
But now all that is gone.
The grandchildren are older.
They have gone to college.
They finished college.
They have their own lives.
They don't remember me at all.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: You can adopt me.
[CHUCKLING]
ISABEL ALLENDE: OK.
You're adopted.
Yeah, good.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: And so
like you're saying,
a lot of us have
immigrated over,
and it's been the Bureau of
[INAUDIBLE] just recently
in the '70s and '70s started
using the terms, Hispanic,
Latino.
And we've been here
long before then.
So-- but we're still kind
of creating our identity
within the United States.
How do you see--
ISABEL ALLENDE: Oh, I
think it's created already.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Yes.
And so how do you see us showing
to the world that, you know,
we've been here long
before anyone else, and--
ISABEL ALLENDE: You know,
I don't think it matters.
I don't think it matters who
came first, because we all
came from somewhere else.
Except Native Americans,
every single person
who lives in this
country has some ancestor
that comes from another place.
So who came first and who came
second is not that important.
I think that what is important
is how we sort of blend
into the culture without
losing our identity,
and we contribute or not
to what this community is,
this large country made of
so many different colors
and voices.
So it is the diversity that
makes the United States
so powerful and so unique.
It's a country
created on an idea.
Most countries
emerge historically,
out of circumstances,
geography, tribes
that get together or not,
language that is common.
But the United States
was created with an idea.
And the idea of the founding
fathers was very clear.
And it's a country
that, with those ideas,
has been so powerful, and
so important in the world.
And we tend to forget what made
this country so extraordinary--
the ideas, the
values, the principles
on which the country was
built, and the people who
came from all over the world.
All that is so
important to keep going,
to keep being what we are.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Yeah.
That's inspirational,
and we're very
excited to continue
to build and show
the world our identity from the
American dream of coming here,
and--
ISABEL ALLENDE: Yeah,
but the American dream
is not white supremacy.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: It is diversity.
ISABEL ALLENDE: No.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: It is
all of us, absolutely.
I have one funny question
that-- since we're here, Google.
ISABEL ALLENDE: Yeah, no
incomplete questions, only
incomplete answers.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Have you
ever Googled yourself?
And--
ISABEL ALLENDE: No.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: No?
You've never Googled yourself.
ISABEL ALLENDE: I
hadn't thought about it.
[LAUGHTER]
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Interesting.
Maybe we should try
to Google and see.
ISABEL ALLENDE: However--
[CHUCKLING]
--I did Google a guy.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
That's the only time
I've Googled anybody.
I was separated from my husband
after 28 years of marriage--
and good terms.
It wasn't something
awful at all.
But I was in a
sort of dark mood,
because I was 73 years old, and
I thought, the rest of my life,
I'll be alone, sleeping
alone with my dog.
Not nice.
Not that my dog is not nice.
No, my dog is nice.
And then a guy, out of the
blue, started emailing me.
And there are a few
stalkers, but not many.
As you get older, the
stalkers diminish--
[LAUGHTER]
--in number.
And so he started emailing
me, and then I Googled him.
But I had a wonderful
assistant, Chandra,
who was like Sherlock
Holmes in Google.
She could get in
Google and get--
I mean, the brand of his
underwear-- everything.
So by that time I met the
guy five months later,
I knew absolutely everything
about his life, his family,
his kids, his car, everything.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Wow, so
Google has a big power.
ISABEL ALLENDE: That
was the only time
that I have used
Google for that.
[CHUCKLING]
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Well,
thank you so much.
I think at this time we'd
love to open up the--
ISABEL ALLENDE:
That will be great.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: --the floor to
questions from the audience.
And we'll have to Google
yourself some time.
See what comes up.
ISABEL ALLENDE: I will do that.
[CHUCKLING]
NATALIE NUÑEZ: It's
always interesting,
and sometimes flattering--
I'm sure, with you, often.
ISABEL ALLENDE: I'm sure
it's not flattering when
you start seeing your pictures.
[CHUCKLING]
That's not flattering.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name is Monica.
ISABEL ALLENDE: Hola, Monica.
AUDIENCE: Hola.
You used the word, blend,
in an interesting way.
Blend-- to sort of
blend culturally, so
that we are seen for who
we are and how we are.
The way that I've experienced
blending as a Latina,
and trying to fit
in, is in contrast
to how you described it.
And I'd like to know,
have you had experiences
of trying to blend that have
been at compromise or at odds
to who you are?
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Well, sometimes
I am asked to speak to Latino
youth, mostly, who have
either come recently,
or they descend from Latino
parents who speak Spanish
at home, so it's a very
Latino culture at home.
And they feel like outsiders.
They feel that they are not
the blond kid with blue eyes
that is popular at school.
And I keep telling
them, you don't
have to let go of anything.
You can have everything.
You can have your culture,
your language, your food,
your music.
And you can still
have everything
that this country offers.
Why compromise for less?
You can have everything,
and keep what is your roots,
and makes you different,
and special, and richer.
Because I speak two
languages, I feel
that I have two different
visions of world.
When I read my
books in translation
because I have to check the
translation into English,
I realize that language is
like blood, so personal.
It comes with your
upbringing, with your DNA.
So keep it.
Don't forget it.
And just incorporate
more and more,
and it becomes a richer life.
And when I say,
bland, it doesn't
mean that you forget or
renounce to who you are.
Not at all.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is Marisavel.
ISABEL ALLENDE: Hi, hola.
AUDIENCE: Hola.
And yeah, thank you
so much for your talk.
Several times, you
brought up letters,
like how you have
written to your mom,
and how you've researched
people's letters
from so long ago.
And I worked in Gmail
for a while here,
so a lot of data privacy
things go through my head
about people's letters.
But my question is about--
now that you have a
foundation, and you're
working with some
of these groups,
that each person has
some stories that
are important to our history.
How can we empower those voices?
Do you, in your foundation,
tell these people,
even though this is
something difficult,
we have to write some letters.
We have to make a way
so that these voices are
heard 100 years from
now, 200 years from now?
ISABEL ALLENDE: Well, there is
a program in the United States,
Tell Your Story, in
which they record people.
They Record migrants,
people who come here
from all over the
world, and they
go into this little cabin in
which they record their story.
And all those stories are being
kept somewhere, and archived.
So now, with all the media
that we have, with all the--
the fact that everybody's
taking selfies, and YouTubes,
and everybody is
in social media,
this is a huge way of
recording what before would
be lost without the letters.
You know, I think that there
are three photographs of me
when I was a child.
No one was taking pictures.
To take a picture
was a major thing.
Today, you take a picture of
a hamburger for God's sake.
[LAUGHTER]
And everything is recorded.
We have a baby that
was born in the family.
And the mother, every single
day, sends out at least two
or three pictures of the baby.
I mean, I know the
baby's butt by heart.
[LAUGHTER]
That wasn't possible before.
So I think we don't have
to worry about that.
The voices are being
recorded better than ever.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So actually, my question
is kind of a continuation
of what you were saying.
When everyone's taking a
picture, and everyone's writing
stuff, and making movies,
then it all gets lost.
So what is that
piece of technology--
the printing press 500
years ago made literature
such an important
part of society.
And now technology is
making it disappear,
because the attention spans
are under two minutes.
We read more than ever before,
but only half-sentences,
or 140 characters.
What is your take on where
it's going in the future?
ISABEL ALLENDE:
You know, I'm very
optimistic about the future.
I don't think that technology
will destroy culture.
I think it contributes, and it
creates a new form of culture.
And I think that
very soon we will
start filtering more the
information that we get,
because we're
overwhelmed with trivia.
And more and more, our brain
gets overloaded with things
that are not really important.
So we will learn to handle that.
We are in the process of change.
Our brains have changed.
Our children are born different.
When I see a 3-year-old working
in a computer, playing games,
and I can't even turn it on.
It's interesting how
humanity adapts to new forms.
And I'm very optimistic.
I don't think that the
stories will be lost,
or literature will disappear.
We all need to hear stories.
It's part of our human
heritage, like music.
We need it.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: And you can
say it's more accessible now,
because of the internet.
You can get e-books,
and have them on you
at any time of the day.
ISABEL ALLENDE: I travel
with 20 books in my iPad.
It's great.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Marcos.
ISABEL ALLENDE: Hola, Marcos.
AUDIENCE: I'm very
glad to meet you.
Hola.
Hola, qué tal?
I have lots of questions, but--
ISABEL ALLENDE: No, one.
AUDIENCE: One, yeah, I know.
[LAUGHTER]
You were saying
that when you write
about a specific
person, a real person,
you usually go and ask them.
What happens with
big characters,
like [? Nedula ?]
and [INAUDIBLE]
that you wrote about?
ISABEL ALLENDE:
They are all dead.
AUDIENCE: I know, I know.
But what I mean is, do you try
to put yourself in their shoes,
and try to imagine what would
they think about the way
you wrote them?
ISABEL ALLENDE: I
have never written
about someone like [? Nedula ?]
while that person is still
alive, and try to create
a fictional character out
of them.
I don't do that.
If I'm writing about
someone who really exists,
I stick to the person,
whatever the person has said.
I would quote that person,
but not invent something
that that person said.
Because it would be so
easy to prove me wrong.
Usually, my historical
books are from the far past.
It could be 200 years
ago, 100 years ago.
I have a book about the conquest
of Chile, 500 years ago.
But if I have someone who--
now I'm writing a book in
which one of the characters
is still alive.
He's 103 years old.
And he's my friend.
And I used him for the
book as a character,
but not with his name.
And I have used the information
that he has given me,
as he gave it to me.
I didn't make up anything
about him, because he's alive.
He'll be dead by the time the
book is published, but still.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ISABEL ALLENDE: Out
of respect, I mean.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Some of the things I
love about your books
is how they transport
me to a different time,
especially in Latin America,
being Latin American.
My question is, it's been a
long time since you left Chile,
and a lot has
happened politically.
What are the major
changes you see
when you get to go back there.
Chile is another country
from the country I left.
But that has happened
everywhere in the world.
I mean, I left Chile more
than 40 years ago, in 1973.
And I left a country that
was under a dictatorship,
half the population living
in terror, and the other half
very happy with what was
happening with the dictatorship
because they were in control.
And 17 years later-- that's how
long the dictatorship lasted--
I went back.
And I found a country that
still was a very cautious.
Society people didn't
talk much at the time.
Now, everything has changed.
But the fabric of the society
had changed in those 17 years.
Plus, the world
has also evolved.
So Chile is another place.
I go back with this
romantic, nostalgic idea
of the Chile I left, which
was a poor, sober country that
was struggling to find
its way in the world.
And I find that totally
different society
that is a neo-capitalist
place, that sort of doesn't
fit my idea of Chile.
But it's still Chile.
People are the same.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: So I do
have one last question.
Are you writing another book?
ISABEL ALLENDE: I am.
I just finished it, like--
well, I will finish it tomorrow.
[LAUGHTER]
I thought I had finished
it last week, but no.
I will finish it tomorrow.
Because I write in
Spanish, I don't
have the possibility to share
the writing with anybody.
And when the book
is finished, I don't
have anybody to show it
to, because my mom died,
and she was the one who
would read the book.
But I showed it to my
brother, and then I
showed it to my former
editor in Simon and Schuster,
who speaks Spanish.
But she left Simon and Schuster,
so still I showed her the book.
And so I'm getting their
input, and by tomorrow, I
should have a clean
copy of the book.
And the book is--
I won't say historical,
because it's very recent,
but it starts in 1936 in
the Civil War in Spain.
And it ends many years later.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Well, we're
very, really excited--
ISABEL ALLENDE:
I'm excited, too.
Because every book is
like a message in a bottle
that you put in the
sea, and you never
know what's going to happen, if
someone is going to pick it up,
if it's going to
be read by someone.
I have written so
many books, and still
have that feeling of
total uncertainty.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: But does
it help, that feeling?
Because I feel
like if you were--
ISABEL ALLENDE: I don't know the
other feeling, so I don't know.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Well,
we're very excited.
ISABEL ALLENDE:
The other feeling
of feeling great about it,
I don't know that feeling.
[LAUGHTER]
NATALIE NUÑEZ: I think we're in
the same boat here at Google.
We're always aspiring
to be great and perfect,
but we're very excited
to read the next book.
ISABEL ALLENDE: And inventing
new things every day,
which is how I feel about
the writing, that every book,
you have to invent
everything again.
And I try not to make the same
mistakes that I've made before,
but I make new ones.
There's always new
mistakes to make.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: That's always--
that's comforting.
[LAUGHTER]
ISABEL ALLENDE: Very
comforting, yeah.
NATALIE NUÑEZ: Well, thank
you so much, Isabel Allende.
It's really an honor
speaking with you,
and I'm very excited
that we had you here
to speak with everyone.
ISABEL ALLENDE:
Thank you very much.
Thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]